[Music]
what is the one piece what happened
during the void century and how will one
piece the possibly most well written
story of our time ends these are the
three biggest questions that every one
piece fan is burning to get answers to
above anything else and every now and
then a theory comes around an idea so
wild and different that no matter how
unlikely it might be to actually turn
out to be the truth it completely turns
our perspective on one piece completely
on its head this is one of these ideas
that has a very unconventional and
radical take on the final twist of
luffy's adventure to become the king of
the pirates and change the worlds why
well because it involves one of the if
not the most controversial tropes of
storytelling time travel and yet even
though i'm usually very skeptic of this
concept myself if what i'm about to tell
you is actually true it would make the
most satisfying ending to one piece that
i personally have yet come across so
based on the most recent developments on
the story we've all taken it for granted
by now that luffy is joy boy whether
that means that he's possessed has
awakened his spirit or simply has
inherited his will many people were
quite skeptical about the idea that
luffy might stop being only luffy but
become a child of prophecy who was
destined to do great things right from
the start and so rightfully there was
the worry that luffy being some sort of
reincarnation might take away from his
achievements and being the special and
unique person who we all have grown to
love in geoform over many many years all
of this now thrown overboard with the
reveal that luffy is joy boy the man
roger and odin and many others have been
waiting for but what if we actually got
it all wrong what if it's one of eighty
or oda's famous red herrings like how
teach said that he didn't have the type
of ambition to become the second
division commander because of course he
had much greater ambitions than that or
how the gomo gomonomi was a mythical
zone fruit all along so what if luffy
wasn't really joyboy what if joyboy was
actually luffy who traveled back to the
void century sounds absolutely
ridiculous at first but you might be
surprised how well this would actually
fit into the storyline overall and so
even if i wouldn't rate this as the most
probable thing to happen in the story
i'm sure you will enjoy the conclusion
to this just as much as i did it all
started with a mysterious message i got
a few weeks ago from a subscriber of
this channel who shared with me a number
of articles and posts about the idea
that the strange world of one piece
might be the result of a time loop or
time leap happening now a lot of these
ideas were basically pure fan fiction
however a few ideas here and there stood
out to me as quite interesting at that
point already for instance how certain
events seem to repeat themselves
throughout the story the government that
has apparently conducted major
cleansings throughout the centuries very
similar people like joy boy noland or
roger repeatedly popping up in different
eras how the void century and people of
the past keep communicating with the
present through objects like the
poneglyphs or inherited will and of
course the parallel between luffy straw
hat and the giant straw hat on marijuana
kept by emu the secret ruler of the
world who by the way looks a lot like a
giant hand on a clock sitting on her
throat and in general as you know time
shenanigans are and always have been a
very very popular theme in anime manga
say for example your name however the
thing that finally got my full attention
on this idea was a two-year-old video by
a smaller one-piece youtuber called
otherwise ace who published a really
really awesome video titled luffy is the
original joy boy from the void century
long before zunisha ever recognized
luffy's awakening as joy boy big shout
out to him i'll leave a link to his
video in the description below okay so
in his video he gives a bunch of
wonderfully collected evidence how luffy
and the straw hats time traveling back
into the void century would fit
surprisingly well with the story up till
now and given what we now know about
luffy and his devil fruit i think this
all has become just the more likely and
fascinating but before we talk about how
luffy and co would even get into the
past let's just assume for a second that
they do for now the most interesting and
mysterious clue about love tale and the
one piece that we've got in the story so
far is the roger pirates actually
arriving there and literally bursting
into laughter most likely after reading
joy boy story as roger himself comments
that he would have loved to meet joy boy
and be bored in the same year as him an
era by the way that as far as we know
was just mainly war and destruction well
if luffy were joy boy that would mean
that raja was actually reading the story
of the straw hats that we have been
reading up to this point as well a story
that is meant to bring us joy with all
its adventures and a quirky crew and
luffy being the person who will change
the world
by going back in time and i think it
would also be hilarious to raj and co
because not only would they be reading
the best story ever but also follow the
adventures of someone who will be born
20 years in their future they themselves
will be included in the story written on
the pony glyphs as well they will know
all about how they themselves helped
luffy reach his goal pretty meta i know
but let's be real how awesome would that
actually be luffy would of course tell
the story where he was from and about
his brother ace and how his death would
be the key to becoming pirate king so
suddenly roger decides to have a kit
that he then entrusts to none other than
garp the man who he fought side by side
with and
luffy's grandfather it would also change
the line of roger wishing he had been
born in joyboy's era and rayleigh saying
that they were too early arriving at
love tale because that would all make
sense if they were talking about luffy's
era roger knew that he would die and
never get to meet him and it is also why
they knew exactly about the 20 years
until joy boy's return it of course also
fits in really nicely with odin's
prediction of joy boy returning and
opening the borders of wano which of
course has now pretty much happened
zunisha was the one who confirmed that
his old companion had returned and who
really better to make friends with a
giant elephant than luffy who we have
constantly been seeing befriending all
types of giant animals throughout the
story the kraken pseudoman the bull
undress rose up the animals during his
time skip you name it now obviously as
you will have already noticed by this
point this idea gets really messy really
fast of course like all time travel
things do like who influences what who
actually changes the future or is
everyone just caught in an eternal time
loop in one piece how can luffy actually
change the present if he is part of the
past oh telling such a story is a real
walk along the edge but if there is one
person i would trust in pulling it off
successfully it is a chilo oda one major
issue with this idea that otherwise ace
mentions with this theory is the fact
that buggy crocus shanks and rayleigh
all members of the roger pirates didn't
recognize luffy as joy boy or did they
interestingly enough however we do know
that it was exactly those three shanks
buggy and croakus that stayed behind as
the raja pirates traveled to the final
islands they were the only three who
never got to read the entire story on
top of that i personally think that for
shanks and croakis you could very well
argue that they did in fact recognize
luffy as i've talked about a bunch
before shanks basically bet everything
on luffy becoming the person roger had
been waiting for the person who did eat
the nika fruit similarly crocus wonders
if luffy is the same man that they've
been waiting for implying that roger was
waiting for joy boy who we now know is
in fact luffy and rayleigh yes who did
go to love tale has been acting very
suspiciously around luffy right from the
start the very first words he tells
luffy is that he always wanted to meet
him the very same words roger used on
love tale i mean even out of the blue he
offers luffy to tell him and the crew
the secret of love tale already knowing
that luffy would refuse and then goes on
to train him personally for two years if
this theory is true rayleigh absolutely
knows exactly that luffy is indeed joy
boy actually looking at it from this
lens makes all of luffy's interactions
with rayleigh just pure goosebump
moments for me like for example when
rayleigh asks luffy whether he can
actually do it and conquer the grand
line that smile he has there is just so
so all knowing he tells robin not to be
too hasty and continue their journey one
step at a time as if to say that they
shouldn't skip ahead to the point that
he already knows they will reach he says
that even if he told him the truth the
straw hats wouldn't be able to do
anything about it anyways the way they
are right now like dude if rayleigh
knows what the straw heads will become
and tell them the truth of course it
wouldn't really help luffy and co at all
they would still need to become strong
enough in the first place and he
literally tells robin that they will see
it all in the end anyways as if he
already knows they're going to be
successful and kind of live through it
themselves now all of this is of course
highly confidential and sensitive
information that rayleigh is sharing
here even without giving away the entire
story and you really wouldn't want that
falling into the hands of the wrong
people like say blackbeard and while
this entire communication is taking
place inside a secure and trustworthy
space on sabaodi the same can't really
be said about your conversations and
activities online luckily there's a
solution for that nordvpn the sponsor of
today's video that will give you the
same peace of mind around your online
privacy as a small cozy and confidential
room on the thousand sunny i've been
using nord for almost three years now i
think because it's super easy to use you
have fast and reliable servers in pretty
much any country across the world and i
can use it across all of my devices and
of course it's great to unlock content
that's not available in your region you
can get your exclusive nordvpn deal
using my link nordvpn.comhara
in the description below it's risk-free
with nord's 30-day money-back guarantee
as well now continuing on that thought
robin might very well have been the one
who wrote the pony glyphs in the first
place including the one on fishman
island that first mentions joyboy by
name it would mean that joyboy's promise
to the mermaid princess is literally
luffy's promise to shirahoshi the last
time that they met in the present what i
love so so much about this theory up to
this point is how it deals with the idea
of prophecy and luffy being joyboy in by
far the most elegant way i have come
across personally
luffy and the straw hats literally being
the one who created the pony glyphs and
telling roger about himself and their
journey telling him exactly when they
would arrive at wano and free it perfect
and it would also open up so many other
fun possibilities like luffy being the
first one to pass on his straw hat only
to receive it back 800 years later by
shanks or frankie being vegapunk who got
left behind in the past you get the idea
and i'm sure you guys will be able to
come up with a ton more as well now
assuming that all of this were actually
true which i think already would require
a lot of assumptions to be true all of
this leaves us of course with another
big question
how would the straw hats travel back in
time in the first place well the first
really good message in this regard is
that time travel has been established
officially as a real possibility in one
piece with the introduction of toki and
her powers for now all we know is that
it's definitely possible to travel into
the future but it opens up the door
very wide to the possibility of
traveling into the past as well one
option would be for example that love
tale itself functions as a sort of
portal to the past which would be
similar to the idea that it is a portal
to the underworld based on the song
being sake that seems to contain a lot
of hints around the one piece another
possibility could be the national
treasure of marijuana maybe the giant
straw hat itself being a device that
allows for time travel which might for
example be how emu and the world
government have remained in power for so
so long who knows maybe whenever
something went wrong they would just
reset that event and make it never
happen in the first place that would
actually be a pretty freaky idea
thinking that the government has
actually been overthrown a bunch of
times successfully before but they just
always changed the past that would also
work really nicely with the image of emu
on the throne looking like the hand of a
clock but by far the most likely option
would of course be the possibility of a
devil fruit having that same ability as
you probably know there are certain sets
of devil fruits that work either as
extensions or opposites to each other
like fire fruit being a weaker version
of the magma fruit or baby fiestrude
being a stronger version of mr once then
there would be opposite ones like bello
betty's fruit and pironas one that
drains morel and one that boosts it or
chondro that can make 2d things into 3d
and jala that turns 3d things into 2d
jala who by the way is part of the same
crew as treble now in case you don't
know i've been trying to overtake treble
in terms of bounty worth this slimy and
obnoxious man has a bounty of 99 million
berries and if you convert all 580 000
of you awesome people into yen
berries basically that would give me a
bounty of 58 million and i just can't
let that stand so please help me
overtake travel now this theme of
opposite or supplementary fruits is
especially true for paramecia type
fruits in other words if there's a devil
fruit that allows you to travel into the
future it would not be all too
far-fetched to have a fruit that allows
you to do just the opposite or maybe
another alternative would be that it's
an awakening ability of the time time
fruit itself now toki is of course a
very interesting character in this
context in particular why did she travel
into the future from the void century
how did she know where exactly to travel
to to meet odin how did she know to send
the samurai exactly to luffy's time
periods and why did she decide not to
travel into the future herself well if
she met luffy and code during the void
century she would know all about the
ancient kingdom's demise being near and
trying to prepare a counter move herself
she would be the perfect candidate to
send the straw hats back to their
timeline and then follow them into the
future to try and take down the world
governments time travel or not devil
fruits will most likely be the key to
the void century and the secrets of the
one piece world and if you truly want to
understand where they might have come
from you really shouldn't miss out this
video right here